to an economist type to drogy Yellen
Clara girtler and the rest of you
guys what does this Market turmoil
signal when you see a when you see the
brutal moves in oil what does it signal
well it really says we're in in really
in a multip speed world you know the US
has had has a decent growth rate perhaps
3% you've got deflation in Japan
deflation risk in Europe China is
slowing you've got both excess Supply
falling demand for oil and now you have
technicals so it's a very volatile mix
right now big countries going in
opposite directions policy going in
opposite directions does market movement
limit the degrees of freedom the choice
set that these different Central Bankers
have is Janet Yellen glued to her
Bloomberg terminal at the FED uh well
I'm sure she consults that a Shameless
plug okay I'm gonna go home now we have
no sound effect for Shameless plug do
but I think the the FED is pretty clear
that they do focus on global events to
the extent they impact their outlook for
the US inflation
or growth picture uh at some level
decoupling is not feasible if you get a
global recession the US won't decouple
OB I am not but I'm saying were we to
get into that stage you would not have
decoupling you also obviously have a
very very strong dollar that lowers
inflation lower commodity prices lower
inflation so that that challenges the
FED as they want to start thinking about
hiking in a year when prices may be
falling Vince beon the other thing
that's moving obviously this morning is
oil as it drops down below 46 um you
know we keep asking you for a number at
which things will really start to change
and you keep saying ah we don't really
know I'm going back to the well let's
start here will they Vince will they
change here does Chevron or Anna Darko
or others do they change their behavior
this
morning so in q1 what we're going to
find is we're going to we're we're going
to see uh the uh the press releases and
we're going to get a flavor for what
that Capital spending is going to be
like for 2015 yeah they they are
resetting their priorities around their
higher return inventory but even with
capex cuts even with capex cuts you will
still see the resiliency of output right
as that price comes on down you are
resetting expectations you're also
resetting expectations from the services
side as well those costs will come on
down and so therefore your break even
costs will come on down somewhat as well
yeah Break Even costs vary even within
plays themselves there is no one
particular Break Even point there are
many producers in the US they operate
all along this cost curve con all right
so rich maybe not Chevron or Ana Darko
but a lot of the smaller players are
very highly levered and we've already
seen a big spike and junk yield how
worried are you about contagion what's
happening this cratering of oil uh
spilling over into the broader
markets broader Market well I think the
the the wild card right here is capital
spending in the oil patch is going to be
down if it's down by a lot thought
that'll impact the overall GDP picture
but so far that's not a major uh impact
penciled in okay I want to bring this up
today and again folks on Bloomberg Radio
I'll tweet this out later uh this is the
New Zealand spread never a dull moment
New Zealand is the kiwi and the coal
mine and they went to a negative yield
the 10-year yield is lower than the
2-year yield in New Zealand no one cares
except Professor Clara I think they do
clear this shows the distortions yeah in
your world now it's an odd World well
think about this way this morning I
heard on the radio in that five year
yields in Japan are now zero indeed on
the bid side they're they're negative
twoyear yields are negative in in in in
Europe inverted yield curves typically
only occur as you say in New Zealand
only occur in environments where you
expect a recession not I'm not saying
that we do but clearly that the multip
speed world we discussed a moment ago is
impacting all asset prices and obviously
has a huge impact on on us interest
rates but we're looking at the multip
Speed World We tend to talk about uh you
know China Japan us Europe you know that
chart about the the the Kiwi inversion
that Tom's pointing to um it really
there are a couple of outlier economies
uh Sweden Switzerland New Zealand um
which behave in different ways sure oh
absolutely well we're just trying to
give broad broad uh generalities
obviously New Zealand exposed to what's
going on in Asia and obviously Sweden
and Switzerland exposed to what's going
on in the in the Euro zone so absolutely
uh Rich of course another one of the big
stories we're following this morning uh
is the selloff in the currencies of many
so-called Petro States the Russian Ruble
back above 65 this morning uh your
former colleague uh Bill gross had an
interview uh with Barry Ritz Hol uh two
hourong interview that you can hear on
Bloomberg Radio this weekend uh but in
it he said he is concerned uh that the
selloff in oil is going to affect the
demand from these Petro States for
buying us treasuries well sure because
they have big foreign exchange reserves
but as they spend them to defend the
currencies that means that they have
less available uh to to to hold on to
treasury so there is some impact there
and I've looked at that and others have
looked at it so far that effect is being
swamped by the opposite effect is people
wanting to hold quality Assets in a time
of turmoil thus 10year treasury yields
below well I I love your use of the
economic phrase swamp there is it really
shows the Dynamics that we've got this
morning